[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire tous commencent à rouvrir
depuis aujourd'hui les commerces les
terrasses des cafés des restaurants les
cinémas les théâtres et c'est l'épreuve
de vérité les consommateurs vont-ils
retourner faire leur shopping com avant
la pandémie
vont-ils se précipiter dans les théâtres
et les cinémas reprenant t-il des
billets d'avion les touristes seront ils
bientôt de retour les épargnants vont
ils dépenser leur bas de laine
la croissance française va-t-elle
atteindre les sommets qu'on lui prédit à
combien de faillite faut-il s'attendre
combien de chômeurs et qui va remplir
les caisses de l'état
pour en débattre nous avons invité
stéphanie villers vous êtes chef
économiste dans une société de gestion
affiliés à un grand groupe de protection
sociale
vous venez de publier avec henri
sterdyniak un livre à deux têtes crise
économique 2020 vers un nouveau monde
aux éditions economica votre pronostic
vous la voyez comment c'est très près de
sept reprises elle va dépendre de quoi
ou de qui on va dire dans un premier
temps des consommateurs parce que les
commerces vont réouvrir et on a bien vu
que
lorsque et bien on est empêché de
pouvoir consommer
comme d'habitude avec ses commerces
fermaient bien la croissance avait
tendance à chuter aujourd'hui les
commerces rouvrent et avec eux et bien
bien sûr la restauration et l'hôtellerie
qui avait été fermée pendant plus de
sept mois donc oui il va y avoir cette
bouffée d'oxygène cette envie de
retrouver nos niveaux de consommation et
nos habitudes en matière de dépenses
donc bien sûr le la fin du deuxième
trimestre et le 3ème trimestre seront de
très bon trimestre avec une réelle de
reprise par rapport au trimestre
précédent qui a été beaucoup plus atone
david cayla vous vous êtes membre des
économistes atterrés enseignant
chercheur à l'université d'angers 7
l'auteur de l'économie du réel en 2018
est sorti il ya quelques mois populisme
et néo libéralisme il est urgent de tout
repenser les deux sont parus chez boeing
supérieur vous vous la voyez comment
cette reprise si reprise il ya alors il
y aura forcément une reprise comme comme
on l'a dit tout à l'heure
lié au fait que les mesures de
restrictions vont être abrogée enfin en
font espérer ainsi la crise sanitaire
s'arrête à les consommateurs pourront
recommencer à consommer toute la
question est de savoir si cette crise
écrit si cette reprise sera suffisamment
forte pour compenser la récession de
résultats et également si elle sera
durable
ça c'est évidemment la grande question
qui quiconque laquelle je n'ai pas tout
à fait de réponse puisque ça va dépendre
d'un tendon de choses que vous refaire
les gouvernements philippe herlin vous
aussi vous êtes économiste vous êtes
l'auteur de plusieurs livres aux
éditions eyrolles sur le bitcoin
notamment dont vous êtes l'un des
spécialistes en france mais aussi de
pouvoir d'achat le grand mensonge
votre votre pronostique philippe moi je
vois au mieux une reprise technique
mais je ne vois pas de reprise franche
parce qu'il ya d'une part un discours de
peur du gouvernement il ya un discours
de peur du gouvernement qui fait que les
gens vont être dissuadés je me rappelle
quand en septembre dernier quand les
restaurants ouverts il y avait vraiment
nettement moins devant les cinémas
c'était pareil et je crains que ce soit
il se passe la même chose
et puis dans le l'autre risque aussi qui
est en train d'arriver
partout en europe aux etats unis c'est
l'inflation et l'inflation ça veut dire
une diminution du pouvoir d'achat et
donc une diminution de la consommation
et ça c'est un risque très grave que
nous courons et c'est à cause des
déficits monstrueux qui ont été faits et
financé par la planche à billets des
banques centrales
et ça c'était une très mauvaise façon
d'agir et on va commencer à le payer là
maintenant au moment de la reprise
alors il faut bien préciser que
l'horizon reste encore pas enfin n'est
pas encore tout à fait déboucher à le
virer lui le virus circule toujours
notamment en france le couvre-feu
continue on continue de porter des
masques donc on n est pas sorti et puis
de toute façon il ya une grande partie
de la planète qui n'est pas vacciné qui
ne le sera pas avant un bon moment donc
on reste dans l'expectative
néanmoins tout dépend maintenant de ce
qui va s'acheter se vendre dans notre
pays
l'économie va t'elle repartir comme
avant les consommateurs vont-ils
retourner dans les stalles de spectacle
que ce qu'ils vont s'acheter des
maillots de bain des vêtements d'été
partir en vacances comme si de rien
n'était c'est un gros morceau qui se
joue là dans l'est dans les semaines qui
viennent stéphanie villers oui mais si
on se regarde ce qui s'est passé au
troisième trimestre de l'année 2020
lorsque la situation s'est peu à peu
amélioré lorsque
les commerces ont été ouverts de nouveau
on a bien vu que est bien là dépenses
des ménages avaient rebondi très
fortement puisque elle avait atteint
plus de 18% par rapport au trimestre
précédent donc je pense qu'on sera dans
le même le même contexte un c'est à dire
qu' il va y avoir pendant cette période
d'estivage une envie de retrouver ses
niveaux de consommation d'avant crise
d'autant que en fait la rémunération
globale des des ménages ont pu enfin a
pu être conservé par notamment les
mesures qui ont été prises de
financement du chômage partiel
donc par rapport aux autres récession et
aux autres crises la grosse différence
c'est qu'on a maintenu le niveau global
de rémunération des ménages qui va
permettre en fait de relancer la machine
économique par la consommation
david cayla oui c'est vrai qu'on a
cherché à maintenir les revenus mais on
l'est beaucoup de mesure des dons
étaient quand même des mesures de prêts
les prêts garantis par l'état
le chômage partiel bien en fait il a
quand même entraîné une perte légère de
revenus quand même pour les gens et puis
à toute une partie de la consommation
qui va pas revenir c'est à dire que les
restaurants qu'on n'a pas fait bas ils
vont pas ils vont parvenir et moi moi là
où je suis un peu inquiet c'est qu'on a
vu un effondrement du nombre de
faillites d'entreprises commerciales
grâce aux mots sur dead c'est à dire
qu'en fait on masque un peu la réalité
puisque on a vu que quasiment 40% des
faillites n'habite ul dans une année en
fait en 2020 on a eu moins 40% de nombre
de faillites et ça continue en 2021
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya des
entreprises qui toutes façons on n'était
pas rentable qui qui ont été maintenus
en survie artificielle distance qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui des entreprises
zombies alors le souci alors on n'est
pas le seul pays à voir salariés
d'autres pays et donc le souci c'est
qu'on ne sait pas quel souvent être les
conséquences
c'est dire que ces faillites on sait
qu'elles vont arriver on sait aussi qui
a sans doute d'autres entreprises qui
voient là qui
faire faillite du fait de la crise parce
que là je parle de faillite qui aurait
dû avoir lieu si la situation était
normale mais on a aussi bien sur le
moindre des soucis pour d'autres
entreprises qui ont dû continue de payer
des loyers conduit continue de faire
face à des charges et qui n'avait pas
d'entrée à parler rentrée les aides du
gouvernement qui voilà qui était quand
même d aide partielle et donc
donc moi moi là c'est une vraie une
vraie question c'est à dire que bien sûr
que les consommateurs voudront consommer
mais est ce que en face le secteur
productif ne va pas quand même sortir de
cette liste de cette crise un peu
affaibli on le voit d'ailleurs un il ya
des tensions aujourd'hui sur sur
certaines matières premières sur sur
certains produits pour les artisans pour
l'industrie on n'arrive pas à trouver
tous les produits tous les inputs soumet
tout tout tout les matières premières qu
on doit utiliser pour produire et donc
il se pourrait que on est un problème
d'offre dans six mois ça m'a parlé dès
maintenant et donc donc dans ce cas là
la reprise pourrait ne pas être
suffisamment forte
alors on reviendra sur le sur les
entreprises et sur les risques de
faillite mais j'avais envie d'attendre
philippe herlin sur sur le sur les
consommateurs d'abord vous étiez un peu
dubitatif me semble-t-il au fond après
le premier déconfinement ils sont la
consommation n'est pas reparti aussi
aussi forte qu'on pouvait l'espérer
c'est ça que vous disiez oui c'est ça
que je dis et on pourra y arqués caudry
française janvier c'est un peu comme le
coyote de bibi plat dans le dessin animé
où il court au dessus du vide sans se
rendre compte qu'il est au dessus du
vide il ya eu tellement de dépenses
publiques pour soutenir l'économie que
en fait c'est trop et ça fausse
complètement les prix et la perception
de la réalité
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont touché
dès le chômage partiel est exposée il ya
eu énormément prêts qui ont été offerts
aux entreprises à clé pge et j'ai
l'impression que l'objectif du
gouvernement c'est pas tellement de de
sauver l'économie c'est plutôt de faire
en sorte qu'ils aient pas d'explosion de
faillite avant l'élection présidentielle
c'est à dire qu'ils font en sorte de
balancer de l'argent public uniquement
pour éviter la grande purge qui manquera
pas d'arriver passe comme le signer
et comme c'était signé tout à l'heure en
2020 il ya eu 38 % des faillites en moi
que 2019 c'est à dire que désormais ce
qu'ils auraient dû faire faillite n'ont
pas fait faillite avec le cowboy avec
les aides qui ont été apportés par
l'état elles vont en profiter et donc
tous ces entreprises là plus ou celles
qui vont faire faillite à cause du
confinement
un jour ou l'autre il va falloir payer
la note et je pense que le l'unique
objectif du gouvernement c'est de
ballons c'est de l'argent public de
retarder les remboursements du pge pour
faire en sorte que cette grande crise ne
se produise pas avant l'élection
présidentielle 2022 sinon ils sont sûrs
d'être des perdants ils vont en faire en
sorte de la déplacer après mais il n'y a
pas de réelle volonté de rendre
l'économie française plus productifs
plus efficace hormis la baisse des
impôts de production qui est une bonne
chose mais je veux dire là on parle un
peu trop dépenses publiques et pas assez
d'eux et pas assez de baisses d impôts
de bas étage rappelle que la france a le
taux de prélèvements obligatoires le
plus élevé des pays de l'osce et des
oeufs donc avec de tel boulet au pied il
faut pas espérer que les entreprises
françaises performe il faut pas espérer
qu'on ait de la croissance genre 6% de
croissance en 2021 comme le premier
bruit de l'onerc un chiffre nettement
délirant il faut pas espérer de bonnes
performances avec de tels et puis aussi
avec toute la bureaucratie qu'emile
avaient toutes les normes
environnementales la lutte conter
passoires thermiques qui va en fait
contre contribué à restreindre l'offre
de logement
donc tout ça c'est des éléments
bureaucratique et dette publics
extrêmement nocif qui ont pour seul
objectif de maintenir l'économie à bout
de bras jusqu'en 2022 et c'est tout
stéphanie villers la hausse de l'épargné
a été très importante depuis le premier
confinement ont dit 160 milliards
aujourd'hui
comment est ce que comme on peut motiver
les épargnants pour qu'ils réinjecte
tout ça dans l'économie et et au bon
endroit parce que si c'est pour acheter
des biens immobiliers sabah sert à rien
si c'est pour acheter des biens
industriels à l'étranger ça va servir à
rien non plus qu'il faut c'est que tout
cet argent aille dans les commerces les
restaurants les services les théâtres ça
c'est français quoi
oui mais je pense que dans un premier
temps c'est ce qui va se passer c'est à
dire que les français vont profiter
comme je vous ai dit en introduction de
cette réouverture de des commerces et on
va pouvoir reprendre notre notre art de
vivre à la française comme c'est dit par
de nombreuses de nombreuses personnes
donc ça ça va avoir tendance bien sûr à
être le moteur de notre croissance
économique je vous rappelle que 60 % de
notre croissance c'est la consommation
c'est pour vous montrer à quel point en
fait les ménages ont un réel pouvoir
économique pour relancer la machine
s'est bel et bien par la consommation
qu'on va pouvoir après adresser un
signal motivant pour pour les
entreprises pour les inciter à produire
davantage et on voit d'ailleurs que les
entreprises jusqu'à présent grâce au
soutien qui ont été donnés par l'état
français mais faut remettre ça dans un
contexte international si vous voulez on
a rien de fait rien d'extraordinaire ont
fait exactement comme les autres pays en
particulier les américains qui pour le
coup sont jusqu'à présent peu
interviewant sioniste
sauf avec cette crise sanitaire puisque
ils ont effectivement injecté à des des
milliards de dollars à des niveaux
jamais atteints par le passé donc en
fait on prend tous à la même méthode
c'est de la dépense publique pour faire
le pour prendre le relais d'une d'une
dépense privée qui était impossible à
cause des mesures de confinement
alors voilà donc dans un premier temps
bien sûr celle épargne qui va pouvoir
être fléché vers la consommation mais
l'étape d'après ce serait effectivement
d'utiliser cette épargne pour le
financement des secteurs d'avenir c'est
bien le projet il faudrait un
partenariat privé public on sait que le
la zone euro l'union européenne a décidé
d'injecter entre 750 milliards d'euros
dans les secteurs de demain la
transition écologique le numérique parce
qu'on a du retard
il faudrait accompagner ces plans
européens part de l'investissement privé
donc parce que pourquoi parce qu'en
europe contrairement aux états unis il
ya une épargne colossale n'ya pas
uniquement cette épargne forcée c'est à
dire que avant même la crise sanitaire
les européens globalement en tout cas
les français et les allemands ont
tendance ont eu tendance à mettre
énormément de côté 1 en france et 150
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par la
crise qu vide mais faut pas faut pas
oublier que en dessous les la partie
invisible de cette époque c'est 3000
milliards qui sont sur les comptes
bancaires ou sur de l'épargné
réglementée donc très peu rémunérés donc
il convient en fait à l'état d'essayer
de 2,2 d'entraîner 7,7
cette épargne a en tout cas la fléchés
vers les secteurs d'avenir parce que
l'argent est là et vite qu'elle a sur
cette épargne cette épargne et le sert
effectivement soit la consommation soit
à l'investissement
moi je suis d'accord il faut il va
falloir quand même pied que les ménages
consomment mais la consommation ne vient
pas sur décision gouvernementale elle
vient aussi parce qu'il ya une confiance
un état d'esprit de consommation alors
j'espère qu'on va le retrouver cet état
mais celle-ci l'on peut pas quand même
le garantir et donc s'il n'y a pas assez
de consommation d'à part des ménages
bien falloir que du coup l'état qui est
le seul agent macro économiques puissent
éventuellement prendre le relais en
lui-même dépenses en dépensant comment
est bien par exemple par par la commande
publique par l'investissement de la même
façon il va falloir qu'on est quand même
qu'on investisse ça a été dit aussi pas
simplement dans les secteurs d'avenir
moi je crois qu'il faut il faut il faut
investir dans tous les secteurs il faut
reconstruire son nombre de filières
industrielles qui ont été démantelés par
par la mondialisation 1
on a bien vu que l'on faisait plus de
médicaments en france on a vu la
faiblesse même de notre industrie
pharmaceutique de notre capacité à
produire des masques
donc ça c'est sur le plan sanitaire
mais à mon avis on a vu aussi dans cette
crise la fragilité de nos systèmes de
production parce que comme on dit en
économie on a des chaînes des chaînes de
production qui sont de plus en plus
longue c'est à dire que on va acheter à
des entreprises qui elles mêmes vont
acheter à d'autres entreprises et donc
on va se retrouver dépendant de toute
une série d'entreprises qui peuvent être
très très très éloignées les unes des
autres
or ça ça pose quand même un problème
lorsque les déplacements populations ne
sont plus ne sont plus faciles c'est à
dire que si vous avez un sous traitant
qui travaillent en chine et vous pouvais
plus aller en chine pour vérifier la
qualité du produit ou pour inspecter les
usines les ateliers ça ça pose ça peut
poser des problèmes donc donc l'idée de
relocaliser une partie 1 pas tout bien
sûr mais une partie de la production me
semble me semble nécessaire mais ça ne
viendra pas spontanément il va falloir
quand même aider les entreprises les
accompagner et je pense que là il ya
tout un champ qui s'ouvre qu'on voit
s'ouvrir aux états unis aux états unis
il ya vraiment un tournant
protectionnistes qui a été en partie
pris il ya aussi le tournant de
l'investissement public puisque le plan
byden le deuxième plan le deuxième plan
byden c'est un véritable plan
d'investissements à la fois dans les
services publics mais aussi dans
l'écologie et les énergies renouvelables
etc
et je pense que nous on est un peu à la
traîne
on est à la traîne dans le volume de
financement qu'on apporte les plans de
relance qui sont plus faibles en europe
qu'aux états unis mais aussi on est à la
traîne dans la capacité qu'on a de
reprendre en main l'économie et de
réorganiser les chaînes de production de
manière à être moins dépendant d'autres
pays donc il faut se le dire c'est que
il faut pas penser que la consommation
même si c'est important je suis d'accord
mais il faut aussi penser
l'investissement et le système productif
et le problème c'est que si on compte
uniquement sur les agents privés pour
investir
on risque de ne pas avoir une réponse
coordonnée aux besoins économiques
philippe herlin ce qu'on peut voir un
tableau le mans reproduire enfin
produire à nouveau un certain nombre de
biens de consommation de biens
industriels dans notre pays
à votre avis voyons on peut le faire la
réalisation est nécessaire mais je
voudrais m'inscrire en faux contre le
fait de considérer que la dépense
publique à la dépense privée c'est des
choses équivalente et que ça peut
produire à la sortie une même quantité
de pib c'est faux la dépense publique
on sait bien que ça génère de la
bureaucratie des gabegies et que c'est
rarement utile je rappelle que la france
elle fait des dépenses publiques
supérieures aux recettes de paix 1975
date du premier budget en déficit
et depuis les budgets du ont toujours
été en déficit soit disant pour nous
pour avoir la croissance si on se rend
compte que des années 70 à aujourd'hui
la croissance moyenne n'a fait que
diminuer donc c'est pas du tout la
solution est le problème de tous ces
dépenses publiques c'est qu'on finit par
la payer par une dette qui devient plus
en plus lourde et par des des impôts qui
viennent de plus en plus importants et
et c'est ça qui pèsent sur l'économie
française
si les entreprises désastre réalise font
construire à l'étranger c'est parce que
le coût du travail en france est trop
important et puis ce qu'il faut dire
aussi c'est que il ya des pays comme le
danemark ont des dépenses publiques à
peu près au même niveau que la france
est à niveau d'impôts au 6 mai au
danemark tout fonctionne bien car voilà
c'est que nous alors que nous en france
on est dépenses publiques importantes
pour un service qui est extrêmement
dégradée et notamment dans l'éducation
qui est crucial pour se réaliser
on a un niveau d'éducation voit dans les
classements pisa route
on voit dans les classements aussi bien
en primaire secondaire que
l'universitaire la france est mal
classée et elle régresse et on ne peut
pas espérer réaliser le pays si on a une
main d'oeuvre mal formés et si on a des
impôts aussi élevé et une bureaucratie
aussi importante donc c'est pour moi
c'est d'abord ça qu'il faut traiter et
certainement pas contre faire encore
plus de dépenses publiques
je crois qu byden c'est justement le
contre-exemple byden en train de faire
des plans qui sont surdimensionnés et
les américains commencent à le payer on
voit en ce moment avec le retour de
l'inflation et retour la passion c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que ça
entame le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs comme jésus à l'heure mais
ça va aussi provoquer quelque chose de
très grave
qui la remontée des taux d'intérêt
aujourd'hui les états financent
facilement parce que le la dette coûte
quasiment rien on la france emprunte
après à zéro ou un peu plus donc le coût
de la dette est très faible mais aussi
l'inflation repart la banque centrale
européenne sera obligé de remonter son
taux directeur les ceux qui achètent la
dette exigeront des taux d'intérêt un
peu plus élevé et là la france sera
coincé c'est à dire que la charge de la
dette deviendra largement le premier
budget de pour du budget de l'état et sa
entravera complètement ses marges de
manoeuvre et cela mettra dans une
situation telle que la grèce en 2010
donc ça il faut éveiller donc j'ai dit
que la solution c'est surtout pas de
faire d'augmenter les dépenses publiques
mais ces deux devenus de faire des
réformes structurelles sur les ducs sur
laquelle était de ducation et sur la
baisse de la dépense publique pouvoir
baisser les impôts et à ce ces
conditions là on pourra réindustrialiser
la france
le fnb l'heure sur l'inflation le risque
d'inflation alors jusqu'à présent en
fait c'est plutôt un effet de base 1
faut quand même le dire ce qui est laid
il ya eu effectivement une inflation en
avril aux etats-unis qui a été de 4%
c'est en partie lié ce que nous dit la
réserve fédérale c'est à dire la banque
centrale américaine a notamment un
rebond dès du prix des matières
premières et en particulier du tout
pétrole je vous rappelle quand en avril
2020 étant donné la force de la crise
sanitaire
le pétrole avait chuté et était de 9
dollars le baril alors que aujourd'hui
il est à plus de 70 dollars le baril
donc on voit bien que et bien ça se
répercute sur le niveau général des prix
alors il ya peut-être sur le plus long
terme un risque inflationniste mais
aujourd'hui faut quand même dire la
réalité c'est juste une constatation par
rapport à une crise qui a eu lieu là
dernière une crise historique qui a fait
s'effondrer les prix
le niveau général des prix donc
attention pas de panique on n'est pas en
train de 2,2 craindre une inflation
aujourd'hui à tout va même si en fait il
ya il peut y avoir des risques
on le voit bien aux états unis le risque
c'est à travers les salaires c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui byden avec son
dernier plan notamment de 1900 milliards
de dollars qui a été déversé à partir de
mars et qui a profité aux ménages
américains parce que chaque américain a
pu recevoir un chèque de 1300 $ + est
bien déçu tu soutiens supplémentaires en
matière d'indemnisation du chômage
eh bien on voit que les américains sont
en train de peser le pour et le contre
et se disent que finalement retourner
sur le marché du travail
oui mais à quel prix dont qui traîne un
peu des pieds alors qu'on s'attendait à
une création des créations d'emplois
massives pour moi pour le mois d'avril
et bien il ya une grosse déception
puisque les américaines sont pas
retournés aussi aussi rapidement qu'on
le pensait sur le marché du travail donc
ça fait une pression sur les salaires
puisque finalement byden annoncé had a
demandé aux entreprises d'augmenter les
salaires pour attirer de nouveaux
allez les amérindiens sur sur la route
du fau le retour sur le marché du
travail
et si et si effectivement et bien pour
attirer de nouveau les américains il
faut une hausse massive des salaires et
bien c'est bien ça qui ferait pression
sur les prix mais bon il faut quand même
se dire que les aides vont se tarir les
aides de
joe biden ça va être
finalement ça va s'éteindre et les
américains et non pas le système de
protection sociale que nous nous avons
en europe et en particulièrement et
particulièrement en france donc de fait
ils vont devoir retrouver un travail et
non pas tant de marge de négociation que
ça sur le salaire sur les salaires donc
moi je ne pense pas qu'il y aura deux
menaces sur le sur l'inflation et comme
l'a expliqué très bien et philippe et
bien c'est bien cette menace de
l'inflation qui pourrait en fait
atteindre les remettre en cause notre
croissance à part avec notamment une
hausse des taux d'intérêt donc moi mon
mon analyse c'est que et bien à moyen
terme il n'y a pas à craindre une
surchauffe sur sur les prix et ce qui
est une bonne chose pour la reprise des
vite qu'elle a il nous reste juste une
minute avant la pause mais je vous la
donne sur le nom mais ça te tenir que
l'inflation c'est tout à fait possible
mais j'avoue que je ne sais pas ça c'est
difficile de prévoir l'inflation s'est
toujours trompée dans ces dunes
dernières années donc je ne sais pas
mais je ne crois pas que l'inflation
pénalise forcément les consommateurs
soient forcément un mal je pense que
d'abord l'inflation favorise ceux qui
vendent des produits
c'est à dire les producteurs regard des
entreprises et un peu d'inflation c'est
plutôt pas mal quoi ça permet aussi de
réduire les coûts financiers donc ce que
ça défavorise de plus l'inflation c'est
le créancier en fait et aujourd'hui vu
que les états sont très endettés un peu
d'inflation ne ferait pas de mal voilà
mais après je ne crois pas à
l'hyperinflation et je prends quelques
taux d'intérêt soient en partie contrôlé
par la banque centrale européenne qui
rachète des obligations publiques pour
éviter justement l'emballement de la
dette
donc je pense que je suis assez serein
mois sur ce qui va se passer on fait une
pause et on continue ce débat juste
après
[Musique]
l'arrivée du coc vie de 19 à neil bon
nombre d'entreprises en difficulté
comment les sauver faut-il annuler la
dette de certaines entreprises
l'annulation de la dette aura des
conséquences il faut le savoir
on aura des conséquences avec les
banques bon j'y étais déjà pas bien en
avant la crise du coc vide cette idée de
prendre en charge de la dette des
entreprises
pour moi c'est un peu plus proportions
gardées c'est un peu c'est un peu le
vaccin du dernier recours
quoi au final on aura exactement comme
d'habitude les mêmes qui vont payer
c'est à dire tous ceux qui payent des
impôts
monsieur bruno le maire se prend pour un
type ex il peut y passer toutes les
dettes les dettes de l'état les dettes
des entreprises etc star simplement si
on se posait la question de ne pas les
faire le deuil ça serait déjà pas mal
[Musique]
deux termes banlieue voire le top 6 tc
forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que les
médias ont un regard on va dire assez
particulier des banlieues et qui dérange
aujourd'hui et en donne cette impression
de la banlieue ça se résoudrait cas des
jeunes violents contre une police qui
serait son travail c'est plus compliqué
que ça on est français on est fiers de
vivre dans ces quartiers même s'il ya
des difficultés est la moindre des
choses c'est d'inscrire aussi notre
empreinte canton quand on participe à la
vie de la société et malheureusement il
n'y a pas cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent des politiques font
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses
mais concrètement politiquement ils ne
le font pas
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat sur la prise avec
trois économistes stéphanie villers qui
publie avec henri sterdyniak la crise
économique 2020 vers un autre monde vers
un nouveau monde plus tôt david cayla
l'auteur de populisme et néo libéralisme
c'est tout
j'arrive pas à lire si il faut tout
repenser pardonnez moi et enfin philippe
berling pouvoir d'achat le grand
mensonge
ma question maintenant c'est sûr les
c'est sur les entreprises et les
commerces à partir de 2022 il va falloir
rembourser les prêts garantis par l'état
vous le disiez tout à l'heure et tous
les tous les deux david cayla et
philippe herlin il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises sont bi c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelle maintenant qu'ils
auraient dû faire faillite et qui ont
été au fond sauvé par le vide et pas les
aident et qui risquent de faire faillite
massivement là dedans les dans les mois
et qui viennent quel est votre avis
là-dessus stéphanie binaire oui alors
effectivement on a maintenu les
entreprises bas à bout de bras parce
qu'on l'a on leur a évité de payer
notamment à l'est les charges et toutes
ces choses là donc les loyers donc ça
leur a permis de finalement passer la
crise mais le jour venu en fait il vient
l'économie va reprendre son cours normal
et les entreprises qui les plus faibles
et celles qui ont un business model qui
ne qui fonctionnaient mal avant la crise
bien sûr vont devoir
et bien offert faire faillite on a vu
que par rapport à la normale
le taux de défaillance des entreprises
étaient en deçà de 2 38%
eh bien il faut prendre déjà il faut
garder à l'esprit que le retour à la
normale
ça veut dire en fait des défaillances
d'entreprises qui vont être supérieure à
40% aujourd'hui donc lorsque on verra
nos entreprises se faire faire défaut il
va pas falloir en fait sans en offusquer
ce sera un signe d'un retour à la
normale n'y a pas une économie qui croît
ce n'est pas uniquement des bonnes
nouvelles on le sait très bien c'est
aussi à des entreprises qui n'est qu'ils
ont qui sont trop faibles et qui
n'arrive pas à générer du chiffre
d'affaires donc il va falloir s'habituer
à ça et ne pas en fait et bien crier
enfin crier au loup en fait puisqu'on le
sait très bien que il va falloir effacer
c'est enfin on va pas pouvoir effacer
les dettes et certaines entreprises vont
devoir mettre le la clé sous la porte
mais néanmoins il ya aussi toutes celles
qui se portaient très bien qui avait
tout l'avenir devant elle et puis qui
aujourd'hui se portent beaucoup moins
bien je pense notamment au restaurant au
café ils rattraperont pas leur chiffre
d'affaires selon lui cela un les
restaurants dans lesquels nous ne sommes
pas allés depuis un an
ben on pourra pas y aller quatre fois de
suite dans la journée la semaine
prochaine donc s'est perdu et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont qui avait déjà
des dettes qui avait investi qui devait
rembourser qu'ils se soient encore plus
endettée et qui vont mettre la clé sous
la porte
ça va être terrible certains redoutent d
des entreprises la fermeture
d'entreprises qui elle était très très
saine est ce que c'est votre cas david
cayla alors ben moyennement enfin et c
c'est possible mais tout de même il faut
dire que les mesures d'être ont été
assez efficace elles ont été assez
efficacement des distribués
ça n'a pas été trop compliqué pour pour
les commerçants de d'avoir bénéficié de
ces aides est donc
et donc c'était c'était absolument
indispensable c'est vrai que les que ces
aides créer une faut un faux sentiment
qu'il n'y a pas eu beaucoup de faillites
que tout va bien et on sait que c'est
pas vrai l'on sait que il va y avoir des
faillites comme comme le disait
stéphanie tout à l'heure néanmoins elles
ont aussi servi à éviter des faillites
d'entreprises rentables
alors évidemment le curseur il est
difficile parce que notamment il ya des
entreprises qui sont saisonnières est
donc dans lesquelles si on les aide
comme on les aide d'habitation si on si
on disait avec un forfait annuel
évidemment ça ne va pas forcément
beaucoup les aider alors le gouvernement
essayait de calibrer correctement les
aides en regardant par rapport au
chiffre d'affaires réalisés l'année
précédente où les années précédentes
pour savoir quel était le montant des
aides qu'il fallait attribuer le chômage
partiel a quand même aussi beaucoup
beaucoup aidés puisque du coup il y
avait plus de charges salariales à payer
ou très peu et puis et puis il ya aussi
eu en fait des aides qui sont organisés
de manière spontanée des propriétaires
qui n'ont pas demandé les loyers par
exemple alors le souci que je vois c'est
plutôt que en fait il va y avoir quand
même un peu un embouteillage parce qu'on
sait qu'il va y avoir des faillites et
c'est tout à fait normal que des
entreprises qui n'étaient pas efficaces
qu'ils avaient des mauve et blanc avant
la crise qui ont été sauvés par les
aides qui ont été dispersées largement
enfin distribué largement ce qui est
tout à fait normal par ailleurs et bien
quand eux on va arrêter de leur donner
des aides et que l'économie va revenir à
la normale ces entreprises on sait
qu'elles vont faire faillite
moi ce qui me fait peur c'est comment
va-t-on gérer ces faillites si elles
arrivent simultanément
parce que derrière les faillites si
payet des fournisseurs il ya des
banquiers et donc il ya des gens des
créanciers en quelque sorte qu'ils vont
se retrouver à devoir chercher à
récupérer parce que vous savez quand on
a une procédure de faillite
tout ça ne prend du temps et il faut
savoir à qui on liquide l'entreprise et
puis on essaie de payer les créanciers
ce temps nécessite des comment dire des
êtres des personnes qui vont évaluer des
liquidateurs qui vont évaluer la qualité
de l'actif pour essayer de distribuer de
payer
les lanciers si on se retrouve avec un
embouteillage de faillite
ça va prendre du temps ça prend beaucoup
plus de temps et ça risque de créer de
l'incertitude et moi c'est ce moment là
qui me fait un peu peur c'est à dire il
faudrait que ça se fasse un peu de
manière transitoire arrive il faudrait
pas qu'on se retrouve en octobre à avoir
à gérer toutes les faillites qui ont pas
eu lieu pendant deux ans et ne pas
réussir à gérer et que les créanciers
ils attendent six mois un an pour
récupérer une partie de ce qui est de ce
dont ils ont droit et là cette
incertitude elle risque d'entraîner elle
pourrait entraîner des problèmes dans le
secteur bancaire chez elles sont au
nombre de deux propriétaires immobiliers
qui attend les qui peuvent pas relouer
par exemple leur local parce qu'il ya la
faillite n'est pas totalement organisée
donc là il ya quelque chose qui pourrait
se passer qui pourrait entraîner un
voilà une forme de stress sur le système
économique notamment sur les banques sur
les propriétaires et sur certains
fournisseurs
philippe herlin oui alors moi je pense
alors c'est vrai qu'on va avoir une
vague de faillites qui à peu près
inévitable mais je considère qu'il faut
pas considérer ça comme une fatalité
complète et je considère quelle
meilleure façon d'y répondre de limiter
ce choc c'est pas de balancer de
l'argent public c'est plutôt de faire un
choc d'offre
c'est à dire de diminuer les taxes et
les charges qui pèsent sur les
entreprises et c'est aussi d'arrêter
d'accumuler les réglementations qui pèse
sur les gens qui font la croissance
économique je vais prendre un exemple
le ministre de l'ecologie avait pas pour
pompili a fait passer sa loi qui m'a
résilience qui va obliger les
propriétaires à lutter contre les
soi-disant passoires thermiques où tout
d'un coup ça devient un problème urgent
là il faut et on va obliger les
propriétaires qui louent à faire des
travaux dans leurs appartements pour des
travaux d'isolation et les responsables
des propriétaires et sadek un
responsable de propriétaire je puisse en
on a fait un sondage auprès de auprès de
ses adhérents et qui montrent que plus
de 30% ne feront pas ces travaux et donc
soit ils remettront à l'appartement en
vente à ce moment-là s'acquittera la
location soit et de l'est seront vides
et donc ça va conduire
à atrophier lob de logements ce qui donc
le premier effet direct ça va être quoi
ça va être d'augmenter les prix des
logements aux locations donc on n'a
vraiment pas besoin de ça en ce moment
1 parce que le avec difficulté le
chômage et le pouvoir d'achat on n'a
vraiment pas besoin que la lho le prix
de la location au des appartements
augmentent en ce moment et donc pas je
considère qu'il faudrait justement
suspendre toutes ces réglementations
notamment environnementales qui sont
très coûteuses qui sont très
bureaucratiques
il faut justement les suspendre dans la
période de reprise pour éventuellement
les met après enfin moi je considère que
on n'a pas imposé soit propriétaire mais
bon à la limite rome et hong lei
quelques années plus tard mais les
imposer maintenant alors que il ya une
crise très dure
c'est que c'est absolument suicidaire
donc là je considère que le gouvernement
s'y prend très mal et que tous aient des
règlementations qui sont qu un objet
politique en fait qui servent à
maquereau et au gouvernement à récupérer
les voix écologistes
et bien en fait ça va se traduire par du
chômage et de des baisses de pouvoir
d'achat pour les français par moins de
revenus pour les propriétaires pendant
au moins 2 et moi de logements location
et donc au final mois de construction de
logements est donc ça va avoir un effet
dépressif sur la filière du bâtiment et
sas avoir un effet catastrophique donc
on nous parle de reprise il faut
justement faire le contraire de ça il
faut suspendre ces réglementations
environnementales pour moi c'est une
urgence absolue qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
stéphanie villers vous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'il fallait que l'argent soit
réorientée par les secteurs d'avenir
l'isolation des logements c'est le
secteur d'avenir oui et puis on voit
bien la nouvelle génération en fait
impose en fait une une prise de
conscience
du monde qu'on est en train de laisser à
nos enfants sur une planète de moins en
moins habitable donc il faut faire
quelque chose il faut que ça aille dans
le bon sens on voit toutes les
problématiques aujourd'hui de du
réchauffement climatique donc étape par
étape je trouve que là pour le coup à
l'intervention de l'état est une est une
bonne chose c'est soutenu aussi par la
manne européenne parce que c'est ce
chantier de la transition écologique a
été portée par l'union européenne est
financé en partie par la bce donc si
vous voulez ce qui nous permet en fait
de financer cette transition écologique
à bas coûts c'est tout l'intérêt de
d'aller vers ces secteurs de en devenir
les secteurs de demain ça en fait peser
trop sûr sur le secteur privé donc pour
moi ça va dans le bon sens et si
effectivement il ya une réglementation
qui n'a pas de sens comme a priori il a
exposé philippe herlin et bien il faudra
effectivement il faudra s'adapter et
être capable de revenir en arrière pour
pas empêché empêcher la reprise mais
globalement il faut voir faut avoir une
vision à long terme on voit que la jeune
génération est extrêmement motivé sur
tous les critères environnementaux il
faut tenir compte de à leurs exigences
et leurs motivations puisque il faut là
c'est peut-être un autre sujet qu'on va
évoquer mais il ya une génération qui
est sacrifiée c'est cette génération
copie d'un qui est l'un va devoir
supporter le poids et le coût que
représente cette crise que vit d'un
ajustement qui va la payer cette crise
que vides
est ce que est ce que ça va être les les
les épargnants certains en parlent
est-ce que ça doit être les riches parce
que toute façon c'est toujours les
riches
est-ce que ça doit être est ce que ça
doit être les multinationales on peut
toujours rêver
est-ce qu'il va falloir s'endetter
encore davantage voilà qui va payer
votre avis divine et david callaham déjà
un type est aujourd'hui quand même les
jeunes payent le lourd prix au delà de
la crise actuellement puisque le bon moi
je me suis je suis responsable d'un
master nos étudiants ils ont eu beaucoup
de mal à trouver des stages ils ont
encore plus de mal à trouver des emplois
ce qui est normal par ailleurs un
puisque le secteur privé étant incapable
de produire étendant donc d'en temps
dans une situation où il a pas beaucoup
de clients et bien il va pas embaucher
le souci c'est qu'il ya pas eu non plus
d'embauché suscité par l'état alors
qu'on avait des besoins quand même dans
les écoles par les universités mais
aussi dans la sécurité dans la santé on
avait beaucoup de besoins et on n'a pas
à côté donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui
qu'une génération qui était diplômé
d'année dernière et qui n'a toujours pas
de boulot où une partie d'entre elles
n'a pas de travail et du coup elle perd
en compétences et les menaces et par
l'exclusion et samos c'est ça qui
m'inquiète le plus aujourd'hui
après bien sûr il ya tous les
commerçants les restaurateurs va pas y
revenir qui ont été comptés durement
touchée est le problème après c'est
comment relance la machine moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est que globalement on
fasse c'est un peu à la mode en ce
moment mais une forme de relance
inclusive c'est à dire que l'on permette
de retrouver du travail à ceux qui ont
été exclus du marché du travail ou qui
ont été en chômage partiel etc ont pas
pu travailler pendant quelques mois
voilà donc donc çà çà çà çà le site de
l'argent mais en fait s'il s'agit juste
de relancer la machine
on n'a pas forcément besoin de faire ça
avec une forte fiscalité
on a aujourd'hui ça a été dit tout à
l'heure des taux d'intérêt qui sont à
zéro dire que l'état peut emprunter à 0
pour l'instant et je trouve qu'il
n'utilise pas suffisamment ce volant là
pour faire ce qui est son le seul à
pouvoir faire c'est à dire remettre non
pas simplement de l'argent comme il le
fait c'est à dire que le souci
aujourd'hui c'est que l'on donne 2
aujourd'hui voilà dépensez vous ont fait
des chèques de 1300 dollars comme aux
états unis
et puis voilà faites ce que vous voulez
le problème c'est que les gens ils
épargnent alors qu'il y aurait quand
même un volet extrêmement utile pour
pour l'état pour relancer l'activité
c'est la commande publique parce que on
parle je parle et quand je parlais
dépenses publiques je ne veut pas
forcément dire il faut recruter des
fonctionnaires
on peut le faire parce qu'on a des
besoins dans l'éducation
je pense qu'on a des besoins mais on
peut aussi simplement commandé à des
entreprises de manière à faire en sorte
qu'elle faisait du travail à faire on
parlait de rénovation des bâtiments
si on attend que les propriétaires sas
les rénovations évidemment ça peut poser
problème peut-être que l'étape facilité
en organisant aussi en facilitant ces
travaux de rénovation on a quand même un
goulet d'étranglement sur sur les
artisans les artisans qui on voit la fin
quand on veut rénover son bâtisse et ses
bâtiments et que tout le monde veut le
faire et en même temps parce qu'ils
aient des aides gouvernementales
on se retrouve à pas avoir d'artisans ou
avoir des escrocs qui viennent bon bah
peut-être que cette filière pour vous
être aussi réorganisé par l'état
colonnes que l'état pourrait aussi
mettre en oeuvre des chantiers ou
susciter la produits des entreprises qui
pourraient faciliter la rénovation des
bâtiments du des bâtiments publiques
mais aussi des bâtiments privés
donc ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que on ne veut pas je peux pas gérer
l'économie
comme s'il suffisait de mettre de
l'argent dans la machine pour que tout
fonctionne ce qu'on voit ce que nous a
appris la crise actuelle c'est un
importance de la logistique l'importance
de la coordination l'importance de la
prévision de la planification et il me
semble que si on veut vraiment que ne
pas avoir à faire payer à tout le monde
et ne veut pas à voir avec une se
retrouvèrent une croissance pro faible
ou qui ou qui ne dure pas eh bien il va
falloir que l'on parvienne à faire de
l'état un instrument stratégique par
lequel est bien on va pouvoir ré
industrialiser accompagner les
entreprises et faire en sorte de
retrouver un peu de croissance et une
croissance qui soit utile à tous d'état
aurait déjà dépensé 174 milliards
d'euros
dans cette crise sanitaire ça représente
8% du pib
philippe herlin pour vous qui doit payer
la note mais juste à voir personne parce
que tout le monde
c'est peut-être justement l'état qui
doit payer la note c'est à dire en
diminuant ses dépenses et en diminuant
les impôts les taxes qui pèsent sur
l'économie
mais en france on a l'habitude à chaque
fois qu'il ya un problème on crée un
impôt quoi donc
mais le problème c'est qu'il ya trop
d'impôts maintenant donc il faut arrêter
il faut sortir cette logique et il faut
aller vers une économie qui sera plus
productif plus plus compétitive plus
efficace c'est ça la france
beaucoup de retard dans ce domaine c'est
pourtant dans ce domaine là qu'il faudra
aller mais je ne sais pas la direction
que prend le gouvernement où tous les
jeux type sont conditionnées par la
lutte conte le soi-disant réchauffement
climatique moi je considère que le
réchauffement climatique anthropique est
un état mensonge est une escroquerie
mais ça c'est un autre débat on va pas
l'aborder ici mais il faudra peut-être
que les gens fassent preuve d'un peu
d'esprit critique plutôt que de gober
tout ce qu'on leur dit gouvernement
pourquoi ces auto fiction en france la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
parce que ça justifie l'intervention de
l'état dans tous les domaines
et comme en france toute la classe
politique de marine le pen à mélenchon
en passant par macro et l air et
étatiste et ben ils trouvent ça très
bien ce que ça justifie l'intervention
de l'état donc moi je dis qu'il faut
sortir cette logique parce qu'elle va
nous entraîner par le fond je rappelle
que emmanuel macron à 10 a déclaré à
plusieurs reprises que la france devait
diminuer ses émissions de co2 de 50 5%
d'ici 2030 2035 bientôt cédant 9 ans si
on fait ça ça conduit à un effondrement
de l'économie parce que c'est fait avec
les technologies actuelles
donc si on veut donc ça c'est une c
c'est la voie royale pour continuer à
désindustrialisé la france donc il faut
sortir de cette logique écologique qui
servent plus à ramasser des voix
qu'autre chose et il faut suspendre et
mettre de côté tous ces législations
écologique qui qui qui vont nous plomber
et qui vont empêcher une vraie reprise
économique
et il faut revenir aux fondamentaux la
liberté la liberté et le fait de pouvoir
travailler et de gagner gagner
le salaire de son travail de gagner
leurs revenus des capitaux qu'on place
et aujourd'hui en france ça manque
singulièrement voilà donc il faut aller
il faut aller dans cette direction et
nikon a mis plus libérale plus souple
plus compétitive
plutôt que d'accumuler de la dette
publique du déficit et 2 et 2 et d'avoir
une sorte de fascination complètement
irrationnel pour cette lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique qui est plutôt
un gros fake qui profite aux chinois en
fait parce qu'en fait c'est eux qui vont
récupérer une industrie quoi donc
il récupère l'industrie innovante des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires donc
ils sont gagnant à tous les coups
et eux de leur côté ils construisent des
centrales au charbon toutes les semaines
donc il fois il faut sortir de cette
logique complètement mortifère est
complètement stupide
stéphanie villers on va pas entrer dans
un débat sur le réchauffement climatique
mais qui est qui qui faut-il taxer qui
doit payer cette note
alors déjà en fait je pense que c'est un
sujet qu'on doit pas abordé aujourd'hui
puisqu'on est en situation de début de
reprise
donc si on est pas on doit relancer la
machine on ne se pose pas la question et
on n'a pas à se poser la question qui
doit rembourser
on sait que nos dettes publiques ont
explosé mais vous avez le la dette ce
calcul toujours par rapport aux pays bas
donc à notre richesse nationale
s'il veut voir c'est qu'en face pendant
cette période où on a mis l'économie
sous cloche est bien notre pub s'est
contractée donc l'objectif aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment de faire croître notre
richesse nationale cela il faut
comprendre c'est vraiment joué sur la
croissance c'est comme ça que et bien
bon an mal an on va pouvoir voir des
bons chiffres enfin en tout cas une
amélioration de ce ratio à dette sur pib
donc vous savez que l'économie c'est
d'abord une histoire de confiance 1
comme je vous disais en préambule on a
les moyens puisque on a mis de l'argent
de côté
donc on peut relancer la machine
économique nous n'allons pas mettre dans
l'esprit notamment de ceux qui ont
l'argent c'est-à-dire les épargnants que
ils vont être taxés à moyen ou long
terme parce que ça finalement sa grille
près
leur envie de consommer ou d'investir
donc il faut dans une première étape
c'est ne pas parler de ce sujet là est
plutôt à voir le verre à moitié plein et
se dire qu'on a tout
allez on a les capacités pour se
relancer
n'oublions pas qu'avant la crise
sanitaire la situation française n'était
pas dans une situation récessive
on n'était pas évidemment dans une dans
une croissance excessive mais on avait
1,2 pour cent 1 5% de croissance on
avait un taux de chômage qui était en
train de reculer donc d'autres la
situation économique de la france était
pas dans un si mauvais état que ça donc
on a cette possibilité de rebondir et
vraisemblablement on verra lorsque la
croissance sera bien bel et bien ancré
comment essayer de de rembourser de
rembourser nos dettes mais la première
étape c'est véritablement la reprise et
la croissance donc david qu'est la wii
non mais je suis d'accord mais le sais
pas ce que fait le gouvernement
malheureusement enfin on a vu la réforme
de l'assurance chômage ac est en train
d'être mises en application qui quand
même sont sista sert des perdants de
fête que sont les chômeurs alors qu'ils
sont pas du tout responsable être au
chômage
il ya très peu de créations d'emplois
encore aujourd'hui même si j'espère
qu'il y en aura mais de la même façon le
gouvernement annonce une réforme des
retraites qui vise simplement à faire
des économies
donc il ya ya mon avis comme un problème
qui est qu'on peut pas être dans une
phase de relance et d'une phase de
confiance et en même temps faire payer
notamment ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup
d'argent c'est à dire des chômeurs et
les retraités pour financer ou
soi-disant faire en sorte de ne vouloir
rembourser la dette
il ya un an un discours quand même de
bruno le maire qui est complètement
absurde de ce point de vue là enfin
quand il dit il faut absolument
rembourser la dette
d'abord c'est pas vrai je veux dire
l'état il fait ce qu'on appelle rouler
sa dette c'est à dire qu'en fait ils
réemprunte quand la dette arrive à
échéance
il n'y a pas de problème de cela de ce
point de vue là parce que il ya une
énorme épargne qui cherchent à
s'investir c'est la raison pour laquelle
est aux intérêts sont très faibles donc
en fait les pagnes c'est à dire l'argent
qu'on a dans son compte en banque
mais en fait il ne sert à rien il n'est
pas utilisé et donc comme il n'y a pas
d'investissement ou pas suffisamment
d'investissements d'un côté et bien
le fait d'utiliser cette épargne pour
prêter à l'état c'est une c'est une
manière utile de le faire parce que
derrière
eh bien il ya toutes les mesures d'être
qui ont été mises en place et donc
rentrer dans une logique où on commence
à dire aux gens et bien la faire baisser
les salaires va falloir baisser les
retraites il va falloir baisser les
indemnités chômage va falloir faire des
économies sur la sécurité sociale moi
moi moi je trouve que pour le coup c'est
pas du tout à un discours à tenir si on
veut être en phase de croissance
donc mon sentiment c'est que je suis
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit
précédemment il faut il faut pas que les
gens payent cher il n'y a pas de raison
de payer la crise du coc vide pour
l'instant en tout cas
et si il y a des soucis si les taux
d'intérêt montre peut-être que là il va
falloir réfléchir sur la manière de
voilà deux peut-être de retrouver des
systèmes de financement mais mais de mon
point de vue le niveau d'épargné tel est
le coût de la dette est tellement faible
que on ne peut pas prétexter de cette
dette pour faire des économies sur sur
l'assurance chômage
alors évidemment je sais que derrière il
ya aussi de l'idéologie c'est à dire
qu'à la commission européenne qui
demande à l'état de l'état français de
faire des économies sur les retraites et
sur le chômage
mais tout ce que ça va entraîner c'est
une baisse de la consommation et ça va
avoir un effet récessif
alors il nous reste deux minutes et
quelques philippe herlin à quoi il va
falloir être attentif d'après vous dans
l'est dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent pour moi j'ai dit le grand
risque c'est l'inflation
voilà maintenant pour revenir sur ce que
j'ai dit je crois qu'il faut il faut
changer de modèle tout le monde tout le
monde dans ce débat comme au
gouvernement comme la plupart des
économistes parlent de dépenses
publiques
et moi je considère que c'est justement
les erreurs à ne pas commettre
il faut sortir de cette logique de
dépenses publiques pour penser à rendre
les cogner françaises plus compétitives
et donc baisser les impôts les taxes et
pour pas que ses ingénieurs déficit dé
baisser la dépense publique voilà et je
crois que c'est juste au moins urgent en
ce moment c'est pas l'argent public qui
va nous sauver c'est l'initiative des
français c'est la création d'entreprise
c'est le travail des salariés c'est la
réindustrialisation en ayant une
économie plus dynamique et et avec moins
de charges
de cette façon là on va pouvoir s'en
sortir voilà c'est fait divers vous avez
traitable attentive à quoi vous alors
déjà voir si les ménages sont bien au
rendez vous pendant la période estivale
et en profitent
profitez des vacances et relancer notre
économie et puis il y aura quand même il
ya une incertitude sur la rentrée de
septembre
effectivement est ce que le moral sera
là pour du côté des ménages et du côté
des entreprises c'est très important
il ya encore on ne sait bien quand même
quelques incertitudes mais en fait je
pense que tout se passera entre la fin
de l'été enfin la fin août et le début
cette début septembre et il faudra
vraisemblablement que le le plan de
relance alors à l'européenne les 750
milliards arrivent à se déverser sur les
économies européennes parce que pour
l'instant en fait nous n'avons pas
encore reçu les subsides de l'union
européenne
êtes-vous david cayla ben moi je suis un
calendrier je pense que la vie devant
l'émoi dangereux vont être les mois
d'octobre novembre décembre au moment où
a priori si la crise est finie la crise
salutaire est fini il pourrait y avoir
des failles en entreprise je serai
allant de 1 très attentif à la solidité
de notre système productif je crois que
c'est ça qui pour moi est le plus
important aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui
donnera confiance aux ménages pour
consommer c'est à dire la reprise de
l'emploi et la capacité qu'on aura de
2,2 de produire des biens des services
utiles et c'est là que je pense que
l'état devra jouer finement lui les
choses en accompagnant cette reprise par
de la commande publique et pas bdz mais
qu'ils soient bien calibré pour
permettre à l'entreprise de valable de
vraiment de commencer à recruter et à
reproduire
je vous remercie tous les trois d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]